eu acho absolutamente fascinante está no
momento de discussões profundas
efervescentes a mirabolante sobre a
cidade efetivamente que a gente quer
construir reconstruir resgatar dentro de
cada um de nós e eu fiquei muito
encafifada pelo fato de a cada vez que
alguém falava cidade criativa está
falando de um bicho diferente do que o
outro entendia
eu convidei então 18 colegas de 13
países
é pra eles dizerem o que é uma cidade
criativa como é que você transforma a
sociedade a partir da sua mudança de
olhar para a transformação sai de você e
de cidades de países tão distintos
quanto esses que estão aqui
propositadamente cidades pequenas
cidades porém será que tem um nexo nessa
história será que dá pra encontrar um
ponto de união dessa proposta e cada
cada autor do seu texto a gente acabou
resolvendo fazer um livro digital que
foi lançado em 2008 em português e
inglês e o que deu pra tirar dessa dessa
estripulia foi que qualquer cidade que
se pretende ser mais criativa para os
seus cidadãos têm pelo menos três
características fundamentais que não são
camisas de força que não são receitas de
bolo mas que são eixos como quando a
gente pede para uma criança desenhar um
rostinho de alguém e ela vai faz duas
bolinhas um uisquinho a gente sabe o pai
lhe o rosto e graças a deus cada um de
nós tem um rosto diferente mas a gente
sabe que tem um rosto base então qual é
a base de uma cidade que se pretende
criativo ea primeira delas claramente a
inovação cidade criativa uma cidade que
continuamente se reinventa é pensando
nesse fluxo histórico das cidades ao
longo do nosso conhecimento sobre elas
mas esse olhar da transformação se dá
sob um contexto que já está né aquilo de
dar a ver o que lá está e ninguém via de
mudar a perspectiva de um ângulo de uma
questão e essa foto é me parece muito
preciosa sempre pra isso porque vem
inclusive do de um capítulo que se
refere à noruega e retrata a cidade de
berga em que um primo e vizinho de
cidade típica escandinávia mas onde
chove o tempo todo e durante muito tempo
os noruegueses ficavam muito chateado
falando assim poxa mas aqui chove o
tempo todo nos turistas 2011 foto pegou
um barco bom
anos e ordem esquecem de citar cidade
como poderiam
de modo que o excesso de água sempre foi
visto como um problema e mais
recentemente na iminência de carência de
água potável já é uma realidade em
várias cidades inclusive a nossa a gente
começa a ter novos novos olhares sobre
isso e eles começaram a desenvolver
formas de captação de armazenagem e
distribuição de água que antes ocorriam
e o que era um problema passa a ser uma
solução mas também inovações das mais
singelas inovações como uma igreja que
não tinha finalidade tinha sido
consagrada no chile virou um teatro de
marionetes
afinal de contas eu não tenho onde sai a
e ninguém pode visitar a igreja porque a
igreja está sendo fechada já que não tem
time conta como uma antiga cadeia na
holanda que vira um hotel de luxo ou até
esta incubadora em tallinn na estônia em
que aquele menino que está sentado atrás
de si manequim desenvolveu esse
gladiador é estranho eu falei isso que
você está fazendo ele fosse na questão é
a seguinte eu moro numa cidade pequena e
eu não necessariamente encontra as
roupas que eu quero aqui e eu quando vou
comprar com pelas sites das dessas lojas
e quando recebi a roupa e
invariavelmente tem um problema alguma
coisa não rola na roupa e eu fico muito
frustrado tem em paquetá e de novo
mandou pra loja e pelas minhas
frustrações eu comecei a desenvolver
soluções e essa solução é um manequim
inflável em que quando estão visitando o
site da loja tira uma foto do meu corpo
e pelas proporções do meu corpo e
consegue ver como a roupa vai se
encaixar e a partir desses olhares de
soluções
a cidade de tallin que passou por
séculos de opressão de cabo de guerra
entre os soviéticos os escandinavos e
todos os vizinhos começou a encontrar
soluções para os seus problemas e
começou a se retrair por até as nossas
soluções como transformar a garrafa pet
material de construção como transformar
pneu em asfalto como transformar fibra
de coco em acidente de carro e como eu
transformo que era um desperdício em
alguma coisa que é mais bem aproveitado
e ficou uma gracinha inclusive que dá
pra brincar de estrelinhas
ou essas soluções para uma cidade que
envolvem que tem um passado de ter sido
a cidade da philips que agora nem mais
philips tem
se viram com 200.000 uma qualidade de
200 mil pessoas grande parte delas
empregada e muitas delas de origem
estrangeira e farão como é que eu vou
reconstruir a casa por uma pessoa que
vai morar lá se eu sei que daqui a cinco
anos vou ter problema que eu tenho hoje
que é por esse edifício abaixo por falta
de manutenção já que ninguém paga o
condomínio
então para que as pessoas venham a pagar
o condomínio eu preciso fazer com que
elas consigam um emprego pra que elas
conseguem emprego é preciso não só
investir em capacitação mas eu investi
em autoestima e o que eles foram
perceber com desvios eram um problema do
desemprego nessa cidade que muitas
pessoas estavam desempregadas porque não
tinha tinta para passar no cabelo porque
não tinham roupa para se apresentar em
entrevista porque não tinham básico
então a construtora começou a
desenvolver todo um trabalho de serviços
voltados à busca de emprego para que as
pessoas saíssem de uma situação de não
adianta buscar emprego porque afinal de
contas eu não vou conseguir uma situação
de rolar tudo emprega meu pelo simples
fato de elas agora se sentirem
apresentáveis não pelo menos uma das
primeiras ações que a cidade de milão
adotou no pós-guerra foi reconstrução do
teatro scala e quando questionaram se
escuta mas vocês têm tudo para
reconstruir um re construir um teatro e
disseram que nos manteve unidos até hoje
ao longo do tempo da guerra foi
justamente a identidade da cidade e não
tem nada mais simbólico a necessidade do
teatro scala
então pra resgatar a cidade agentes é
resgatar a autoestima das pessoas
inclusive do ponto de vista da sua
inserção nesses fluxos econômicos e
sociais e talvez um dos casos mais
emblemáticos seja o que não chega sempre
da colômbia de gottardi e maybelline ele
já foi a cidade mais violenta do mundo e
passou a se transformar num ícone de
possibilidades alternativas
o prefeito antanas mokus quando foi
eleito em bogotá
o antigo reitor da universidade eleito
sem partido como voto de alternativa ao
que vinha ocorrendo na cidade uma das
primeiras ações como vocês acompanharam
em outra cidade inclusive na nossa como
tentativa de implementação foi contratar
mímicos tanto cansado de investir em
educação de trânsito e ninguém respeita
a faixa de pedestre também contratou os
mímicos ficavam nos grandes cruzamentos
de modo que quando fechava o farol tinha
um pateta em cima da faixa de pedestre o
mímico
o jeito mineiro de ser batida no carro
saiu dando cambalhotas virar um mico
incrível do cara que tava dentro do
carro de modo que ninguém nunca mais
parava na faixa de pedestre não respeita
o pedestre mas não pagar mico
e essa história de fazer com que o outro
se sinta responsável pelo espaço público
é uma das primeiras questões pra gente
resgatar a autoestima da cidade ea
cidade ser feita por cidadãos não vai
recuperar se as pessoas tiverem
deprimidas e quando a gente entra numa
cidade como são paulo e invariavelmente
sai para as ruas as pessoas estão de
cara amarrada mas quem fala de
criatividade sem na risada mas falta de
criatividade se as pessoas olharem nos
olhos
então a gente tem que pensar nessas
questões até inovações como novos
modelos de governança a história da cufa
que emblemática aquino chega de roterdã
também o processo recente em que um
grupo de pessoas ocuparam o edifício
maiores cotas tiveram autorização da
prefeitura propõe edifício maria que não
tinha mais trânsito e eles pelo pela
vivacidade do começaram a desenvolver
nesse edifício pequenos ateliês pequenas
galerias pequenas festas pequenos de
tudo aquilo tomam outra configuração na
cidade até continuar questionando a
senhora gente né conseguiu resgatar esse
bairro que estava perdido da dinâmica da
cidade ea gente já reuni lo a cidade
inclusive com uma passarela física ea
prefeitura pela beleza daqui a 30 anos
você vai ter sua passarela assim é tá
bom e fizeram o crowdfunding acho que
produção nem serve pra isso não pretende
editar o próprio cd mas para resolver
questões da cidade né
é preciso que a extensão do coletivo
porque se é claudio tem de ser coletivo
e esses eram produtos também para que
cada pessoa que o ano 25 euros tivesse
seu nome nesses políticos de sorvete que
vieram a constituir a passarela
a passarela foi inaugurada uma tremenda
de uma festa mas mais importante do que
a passarela física foi a passarela que
as pessoas envolveram nos seus corações
com a cidade e as futuras passarelas que
já estão desenvolvendo em seus planos
para fazer com que a cidade se reconnect
ea prefeitura vocês podem imaginar agora
juntando andar aqui mas eles querem né
porque agora estou tendo que mostrar
serviço e essa questão de conexões junto
com as inovações é superimportante
porque de novo a gente mora no conjunto
sinto de espaços completamente
desarticulado na representação que cada
um de nós faz da cidade de são paulo é
uma pinha muito limitado e dentro desse
mapeamento limitado que é o local onde a
gente mora onde a família mora um dos
amigos estão disse de onde a gente
trabalha ponto os nossos mapas afetivos
aquilo que de fato importa pra gente
ainda são muito menores
mas a cidade está falando se o meu mapa
não bate com dori al e do leão no bairro
helena helena bate com ninguém aqui está
falando de uma esquizofrenia é coletiva
e não há efetivamente uma cidade para
resgatar essas conexões têm n coisas que
a gente pode fazer né
até resgata as histórias da cidade uma
das coisas mais famosas em que todo
mundo bate ponto quando vai a uma cidade
por exemplo como londres é fazer os tais
usando nox e da encontra uma pessoa na
saída de um metrô com guarda-chuva ver
todo mundo vai fazer o circuito de jack
o estripador aaa a fulaninha foi
esquartejado em pé então garante que
errou
aqui a gente tem um zilhão de cidade
histórias que ninguém conhece a gente
anda pra igreja de santa efigênia ver
marcas de bala da evolução de 24 anos
estava parado olhando para a parede com
a marca de bala evolução de 24 fazendo
referência a passar seis anos passaram
12 meninos ficaram me olhando com aquela
seu ela pirou de vez o treino é uma
coisa que eu não tô e não resisti e
perguntei por que você tá vendo eu
fiquei tão contente e vou contar a
história e evolução de 24 para a senhora
tá vendo aqui marca de bala e antes que
eu seguisse no meu relato virou produto
assim nossa pc passou até aqui eu falei
que a gente conhece da história da
cidade
como é que a gente vai tava aqui foi
demolido bota uma plaquinha dizendo
existiu pronto e resgatar o que ainda
existe a questão dos rios um processo
deliciosos como dos rios e ruas né de
pessoas incríveis que estão fazendo e se
esse mapeamento dos cursos d'água da
cidade de são paulo que só brincar ali
do lado da gvt em uma nascente onde tem
um cidadão ali o típico sup o que fica é
lavando carros das pessoas que vão para
a tv
há 30 anos o mago de nascente ea gente
passa pra quem não sabe que tem assim
como a gente não sabe nada disso é só
uma brincadeira que eles fazem colocam
esse mapa que o mapa do subterrâneo a
gente mora numa ilha
uma hora é de fato uma cidade ea gente
se perde completamente o meu deus onde
fica o norte
cadê o que tem aqui de baixo e daí
quando a gente começa a fazer os
caminhos pela cidade andando de
bicicleta gente fala para isso aqui pode
ser um curso d'água é porque a água vai
para lugar queimar óleo lima na parede
onde a vegetação que está ali ea gente
começa a se reconectar com a própria
cidade e outra conexão que eu acho que é
super importante por uma pessoa que
sente cidade manhã a são paulo uma
cidade muito fria
nossa muito distante foi quando tem
cidade mais acolhedora a gente tem gente
que tudo quanto é canto todo mundo é
recebido e todo mundo desce a lenha na
cidade
mas quais são as sensações que a cidade
desperta pelo lado positivo também não
só as que detonam a cidade
isso eu acho que foi um trabalho dos
mais gostosos é que a spturis fez em que
eles vão fazer um mapa das sensações e
perguntaram a cidade de são paulo os
cidadãos da cidade de são paulo por
nascimento para acolhida
quais são seus lugares vinhos especiais
que desperta uma sensação
a ew perfume do pãozinho quando saiu da
padaria de um ser que há é aquele gosto
do pastel do mercado
nossa é aquela luz quando chega o final
da tarde bate em cima da falsa figueira
e na vila brasil o que fosse e eles
construíram um novo mapa da cidade de
são paulo em cima das sensações dos
paulistanos não tem como a gente se
reconecta um espaço se não for pelo
coração também a gente nos reconectar
pela cabeça e é o que eu chamo de
síndrome do bolo de chocolate em que a
gente fala a sinceridade são paulo é
super criativa porque tem a vila
madalena o rio de janeiro é super
criativa por que tenha lapa porque o
bolo só tem chocolate mas quando a gente
pára para pensar e falar assim cadê o
ovo da cidade é da farinha da cidade que
deu açúcar que ninguém vê mas sem ele o
bolo não funciona
eu acho que tem que resgatar os outros
ingredientes da cidade de são paulo para
parar de pensar que a cidade é o
chocolate e que mais gente traz para
esse bolo que é tão própria é tão único
e tem um gostinho tão especial mas junto
com inovações conexões a terceira e
última característica que a gente
encontrou comum esses olhares todos
sobre cidades criativas e agricultura e
cultura como identidade da cidade
cultura como é impacto econômico também
mais cultura sobretudo por esse
ecossistema que é mais propício
a gerar olhares diferentes cultura como
que vem sendo trabalhado muito
fortemente no peru que o resgate da
gastronomia algo profundamente vinculado
à cultura do país mas em especial de
lima com toda a valorização do iene
tipos de tuberculose têm uma uma
fascinante é gastronomia paulistana para
além do restaurante dom e das centenas
de pizzarias a gente não conhece né do
churrasquinho da esquina até as coisas
mais absurdas que surgem porque a gente
não sabe pronunciar na feira é aos
sábados quando encontra as barraquinhas
bolivianas
a gente tem uma profusão de coisas que a
gente não reconhece atitudes como essa
de um fotógrafo chileno foi assim as
pessoas cruzam com vizinhos não sabem
que era vizinho e ele resolveu começar a
sair pela rua tirando fotos das pessoas
pois um lambe-lambe na frente da
prefeitura foi o tiro foto de graça e as
pessoas começaram a sair as fotos e
quando ele organizou a exposição todo
mundo foi lá pra ver se a foto estava e
daí quando cruzava com um vizinho na rua
falando assim você não é aquele cara ela
se estava na foto né
olha que coisa doida agentes e do olhar
do outro por reconhecer o vizinho não é
porque a gente não conhece vizinho fazer
essas conexões improváveis eu adoro essa
cultura vem da da lituânia gente passa
dia não entende nada porque não tem
olhos para ligar passa a noite e percebe
que na verdade a sombra da escultura que
se projeta sobre o muro e está semeando
sonhos eu acho que são esses olhares de
novas conexões conexões improváveis que
a gente tem que trazer para fomentar a
criatividade numa cidade como são paulo
e isso só se dá quando a gente encontra
outras tribos quando a gente faz
pequenas e grandes estripulias tiros
espetáculos de dentro do teatro só e
coloca nas ruas porque a gente não faz
ensaio aberto porque não faz um ensaio
aberto no meio da praça na escadaria de
algum lugar simplesmente pra passar
música e não para treinar equipamento
como é que a gente usa melhor os espaços
da cidade não pensa sempre nas caixinhas
ou até questões muito mais singelas como
a de natal na casa da ribeira em que um
dois três meninos resolveram botar na
cabeça que eles iam pegar uma casa
antiga em comprar essa casa antiga que
era uma antiga padaria transformar
aquilo num teatro que eu tinha
de referência da cidade e que faz com
que num bairro que é o bairro da ribeira
que poucas pessoas freqüentam que vive
sendo mordido pelos empreendimentos
voltados ao posto agora há dez anos os
jovens artistas da cidade consiga ter um
espaço de apropriação do que a própria
do que a sua cidade do que a cidade
deles é esses olhares todos que vinham
chegando por conta dos cursos das
palestras os projetos consultoria esses
revelando os nossos várias cidades de
são paulo nos levaram a lançar uma
iniciativa da fecomércio sesc senac
chamado samba criativa ponto org.br que
é um portal para estimular e coletar
propostas do cidadão paulistano para a
sua cidade ele fosse mas como é que a
gente vai tentar dar alguma dica alguma
diretriz de como as pessoas podem se
encontrar dentro dessas propostas ea
gente resolveu propositadamente sair dos
setores porque não adianta falar por
pessoa você pode resolver os problemas
da sociedade por exemplo a gente tem um
problema grave de saneamento público no
coitado do cidadão para conseguir sobre
saneamento público combinado mas como é
que ele pode pensando em eixos
transversais de governança de inovações
sociais de negócios de diálogos de
espaço público ele pode transformar a
sociedade a partir dessas pequenas
grandes maravilhosas iniciativas como
essa foram comentados aqui antes também
então exportar surgiu para isso foi
lançado terça feira já está recebendo um
monte de propostas e idéias não é que
ele simplesmente como repositório é
agente semanalmente e vai sistematizar
as propostas encaminhadas para a câmara
de vereadores que já está acompanhando
esse processo de construção para a
prefeitura para as instituições
parceiras a idéia não é inventar a roda
a gente está fazendo uma rede com nossa
são paulo virada sustentável instituto
europeu de design escola são paulo todos
da democrática todo mundo que quiser
entrar a bordo porque eu acho que a
gente se alavancar tudo o que já vem
sendo feito individualmente para poder
dar mais força nas propostas de
transformação da cidade alcance de nós
paulistanos né
acho que já deu também a gente fala
assim puxa vida à cidade de são paulo
não tem jeito vamos resgatar a cidade de
são paulo a cidade de são paulo tem
dentro de nós né eu peguei a minha
árvore tinha ele como símbolo estou
colocando meu no meu mural de cortiça
na frente da minha mesa e toda vez que
eu falei meu deus cidade de são paulo
será que não tem jeito olha que ela vai
falar assim pois ela sobrevive né
eu tenho que sobreviver também então
acho que a gente pode muito resgatar
essas questões deixo aqui o convite a
vocês participarem divulgarem tuitarem
facebook karen o que for porque
efetivamente uma nova forma de
comunicação que está tentando fazer como
voz do cidadão que é quem mais entende
da cidade
obrigado